[Musique]
bienvenue sur les bords de Loire dans
cette vallée bénie des dieux berceau de
la Renaissance française classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité le Val
de Loire accueille les plus beaux
trésors de France Vallée des Rois jardin
de la France la vallée nigérienne et
parsemé des châteaux les plus
prestigieux posés sur un échiquet de
verdure où coule le plus long fleuve
d'Europe cette région fut marquée par
les femmes les plus raffinées de leur
temps qui ont imposé et ce que l'on a
appelé l'art de vivre à la française
c'est grâce à la rencontre dans le Val
de Loire des cultures italiennes et
françaises qu' né la Renaissance et le
château de Blois où je me trouve
actuellement en est l'un des plus beaux
exemples
Amboise chambor chenonau usé valenet
vilandri entre autres nous ont ouvert
leur domaines qui pour certains d'entre
eux sont fermé au public ce sont les
trésors du valde
Loire
nous allons vous faire découvrir les
châteaux de la Loire comme vous ne les
avez jamais vu à travers les
chef-dœuvres insoupçonnés dissimulés
derrière leurs murs des chef-dœuvres qui
ont croisé les destins des plus grands
personnages de notre
histoire de Charles VI à Henri II les
Valois ont transformé la région ayant
découvert en Italie une nouvelle
esthétique ils n'ont eu de cesse de la
trans
dans le Val de Loire le roi de France va
découvrir la Renaissance italienne et
pour lui c'est évidemment un choc cela a
donné la Renaissance française et ses
joyaux comme Amboise Blois chambor ou
encore AZ le rideau qui tente de
retrouver aujourd'hui sa splendeur
passée la Renaissance s'est accompagnée
d'une nouvelle manière de vivre avec les
jardins la mode la
culture
cet art de vivre inédit et unique est le
symbole de l'excellence et du
raffinement à la
françaisevente un phénomène qu'on va
appeler la mode entre fêt somptueuses et
guerre de religion nous allons revivre
les plus grands événements de la
Renaissance mais le Val de Loire ne se
limite pas à cet âge d'or au cours des
17e et 18e siècle la vallée nigérienne
va devenir un lieu de plaisance où l'art
de voir n'ura d'égal que la beauté de
ces châteaux et leurs jardins à la
française les esprits les plus brillants
vont se retrouver dans les salons de
Cheverny US ou mena dans ces châteaux on
se cultive on apprend on parle on
discute on échange on peut jouer de la
musique enfin vous allez découvrir
qu'après la Révolution française et
jusqu'au 20e siècle les châteaux de la
Loire entreront de plein pied dans la
modernité
de Taleran à Wallis Simpson la duchesse
de Winsor les châteaux de valencet Candé
ou vilandri vont à leur tour entrer dans
la légende du valde
Loire on voit la robe du mariage que
portait Wellis Simpson célèbre
évidemment par son bleu qu'on a surnommé
le bleu
Wellis autant d'histoire passionnante
vécu dans ces monuments reflet d'un
génie et d'un rayonnement unique qui
font du valde Loire un somptueux théâtre
de l'histoire de
[Musique]
France au Moyen-Âge le Val de Loire est
une région parsemée de forteresses
austères s'il est devenu le creuset de
tous ces trésors c'est en grande partie
grâce à la guerre de 100
ans nous sommes au début du 15e siècle
Charles VI devient le roi de
France les Anglais ont envahi le nord du
royaume et pris Paris le roi se réfugie
avec sa cour dans la forteresse de
Chinon le roi Charles VI est contraint
de s'enfuir il s'enfuit où de de l'autre
côté de la Loire pour se mettre à l'abri
grâce à la Loire qui est une ligne de
défense face à une éventuelle menace des
[Musique]
Anglais cette position stratégique offre
une sécurité maximum aux jeunes rois le
Val de Loire devient le berceau du
royaume les grands seigneurs qui
l'entourent tout naturellement vont
venir s'installer dans ce secteur
ensuite les hauts fonctionnaires les
grands commis du royaume les hommes dont
il a besoin vont être trouvés dans la
région tourangel et c'est cela en fait
qui explique aujourd'hui encore la
densité incroyable de château dans la
région qu'on appelle la région
ligérienne c'est-à-dire la région de la
Loire ils y trouvent également quelques
avantages il y a une certaine douceur
dans le Val de Loire on parle comment
dire de la douceur en jevine
[Musique]
on parle aussi du jardin de la France et
ça c'est tout à fait intéressant parce
que quand on se promène dans le Val de
Loire et bien l'on voit des paysages
très doux des collines mais aussi des
champs et des terre très fertile on voit
des vignobles et l'on sent que la terre
est
[Musique]
riche cette région va désormais être au
cœur de de France et donner naissance à
ses plus beaux
trésors cette région sera aussi le
symbole de l'amour et des femmes un
amour que Charles VI va porter avec
passion à une jeune femme de sa
cour c'est la première favorite
officielle de l'histoire de France c'est
agès Sorel elle a eu une influence sur
la vie de la cour partout où elle se
trouvait et donc les châteaux vont être
un peu mieux organisé mieux arrangé
mieux meublé mieux équipé mieux aéré
mieux éclairé qu'il ne
[Musique]
l'était la première favorite de
l'histoire de France aura une influence
considérable sur les châteaux de la
Loire à commencé par le château de loche
que Charles VI lui offre en
1444 ce château est à ce moment-là
embelli par laadjonction de nouveaux
bâtiments pour permettre d'héberger agès
Sorel l'oche situé à une soixantaine de
kilomètres à l'est de Chinon est un
bijou d'architecture du Moyen-Âge et de
la prérenaissance
[Musique]
française on se rend compte donc que ce
bâtiment n'est plus un bâtiment
militaire c'est un ouvrage largement
ouver ouvert sur l'extérieur par ces
fenêtres qu'on appelle des croisé ou
bien même par ces balcons on a envie de
profiter du paysage on se permet
d'avantage de luxe vous voyez on se
permet de construire un bâtiment fait
pour la plaisance pour le
plaisir agès Sorel insuffle à la cour un
véritable renouveau artistique un art de
vivre annonciateur de la Renaissance
elle invente un phénomène qu'on va
appeler la mode en portant des vêtements
jugés très audacieux agès invente le
décolleté qui découvre entièrement ses
épaules ces coiffures sont de véritables
[Musique]
pyramide des traines prolongent ces
robes brodées de Mart au
zblin
deux trésors du 15e siècle les portraits
d'Agnès Sorel par Jean Fouquet et
François Clouet nous dévoilent les
critères de beauté qui ont révolutionné
son époque et surtout choqué les
chroniqueurs
religieux Agnès Sorel scandalise
l'église à certains égards les
extravagances de sa tenue par exemple
apparaissent aussi comme quelque chose
qui n'est pas forcément recommandable
aux yeux de
l'église
pour tempérer le courou des autorités
religieuses elle va se montrer très
généreuse avec les chanoine de la
collégiale de looche situé juste à côté
du logi
Royal c'est d'ailleurs ici qu'à sa mort
en 1450 Charles 7 éploré va vouloir
l'inumer dans un magnifique tombeau de
marbre qui se trouve dans le cœur de la
collégiale de loche où son corps
désormais va reposer
[Musique]
ce type de tombeau tout d'albâtre et de
marbre noir sculpté d'or était jusque là
réservé au dépouilles du couple royal
faisant fi du scandale Charles 7
consacre sa belle avec cette sépulture
et en fait une presque
[Musique]
reine
quelques années plus tard Charles VI et
Anne de Bretagne vont s'installer à 40
km de loche au château
[Musique]
d'Amboise ils vont faire entrer le Val
de Loire puis le royaume tout entier
dans la Renaissance
[Musique]
française
le rêve de Charles 8 et d'anne- de
Bretagne c'est de faire d'Amboise un
palais au goût nouveau c'est-à-dire
confortable et un endroit qui soit
prestigieux le roi entreprend de grands
travaux sur la forteresse médiévale
construite sur un plateau en surplomb de
la
Loire et bien l'on sait qu'il y a sur
place 178 tailleurs de pierre et maçon
on sait qu'il y a 50 à 70 manouvriers
sans compter donc les les charpentiers
et les couvreurs donc il y a là toute
une petite troupe de bâtisseurs qui
s'emploi à construire sur les bords de
la Loire une résidence véritablement
royale pendant ce temps Charles VI mène
campagne en Italie la guerre le conduit
jusqu'à
Naples mais pendant ce séjour à Naples
le roi de France va découvrir la
Renaissance italienne et pour lui c'est
évidemment un
[Musique]
choc
il faut se souvenir que à la fin du 15e
siècle le roi de France réside encore
dans de vieilles forteresses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
médiévales en fait il a envie d'adop
on le sent cette architecture nouvelle
et moderne de la renaissence découverte
en Italie dans la vallée de la Loire on
savait faire des châteaux et on découvre
un nouveau
[Musique]
modèle et c'est du croisement de ces
deux influences que sort progressivement
la nouvelle forme qui est celle des
châteaux de la
[Musique]
loi
on a cette espèce de combinaison qui
donne naissance à ce qu'on appelle
parfois le style fleuri des châteaux de
la Loire c'est-à-dire un style qui mêle
la finesse la profusion décorative du
gothique flamboyant avec les symétries
d'avantage marqué les quadrillages plus
réguliers qui vont être le propre du
style inspiré par
l'Italie sur le chantier d'Amboise on
voit surgir l'aile d Charles VI avec le
logi royal mais rien ne symbolise mieux
la modernité d'Amboise que son
ingénieuse tour des
Minimes cette tour cavalière est l'un
des plus beaux exemples d'innovation de
la fin du 15e
[Musique]
siècle cette tour a l'air d'une tour de
défense mais c'est une illusion c'est un
leur puisque c'est une porte d'entrée
c'est une rampe qui fait cinq boucles et
qui permettait aux chevaux et aux
atelages de passer du niveau de la ville
au niveau des terrasses du
château ce sont des croisés d'ugive qui
reposent sur des murs le mur extérieur
c'est la silhouette massive du château
et à l'intérieur c'est ce cylindre vide
sur lequel donc s'appuie ce grand chemin
d'accès
le règne de Charles VI va marquer un
renouvellement profond de la manière de
vivre la nouvelle cour de France devient
le cadre d'une révolution esthétique et
spirituelle la Renaissance dont ce
trésor qu est Amboise sera le
[Musique]
laboratoire
après Amboise c'est le château de Blois
qui va avoir les honneurs du roi de
France Louis XI succède à Charles vi8 et
prend pour épouse Anne de Bretagne il
grandit ici à Blois il en a donc fait sa
résidence principale et entreprend la
reconstruction du château je me trouve
d'ailleurs dans l'aile qui porte son nom
dorénavant on va oublier le caractère
défensif des forteresses pour
s'acheminer vers plus de raffinement
l'influence italienne va ouvrir les
châteaux vers les jardins qui ne sont
plus clos cette influence va se voir
aussi avec la création du couloir que
l'on appelait à l'époque une galerie
comme cette galerie Louis XI qui
accueille aujourd'hui le musée des
beauarts de vrais trésors y sont
conservés et notamment cette tapisserie
du 16e siècle sur laquelle on voit le
château de Blois ou ce porc épique doré
au-dessus de la chambre du roi qui date
de la Renaissance la nouveauté à
l'époque c'est que ces galeries
permettent d'accéder aisément à chaque
salle sans être contraint de traverser
toutes les pièces selon l'usage français
et ce n'est qu'un début l'influence
italienne va permettre à Blois d'entrer
dans la Renaissance
française à partir de
1462 Blois devient la résidence favorite
des rois de France
elle le restera pendant plus d'un
[Musique]
siècle château de Blois château de roi à
Blois le roi s'impose jusque dans
l'architecture dans la cour d'honneur
une statue équestre de Louis XI
accueille le
visiteur cette présentation du roi
au-dessus de la porte de son château
signifie qu'il domine le royaume à
l'extérieur du château comme il est le
maître à l'intérieur du château cette
statue est donc une affirmation de de
majesté une affirmation de
souveraineté Louis X va entouré des
meilleurs artistes italiens leur
influence va se faire sentir surtout
dans
l'ornementation dans l'aile Louis XI la
galerie qui a été constituée peut être
considérée comme la transition entre le
style gothique et la Renaissance donc on
passe à une autre
époque mais c'est dans les jardin du
château que transparaît réellement la
révolution de cette toute nouvelle
résidence royale
rompant avec le jardin médiéval clos et
strictement nourricier le roi souhaite
profiter de la nature et crée des
jardins à l'image de ceux de Vilander
aujourd'hui Louis X va créer des jardins
très importants le jardin devient ce
qu'il va être peu à peu à la Renaissance
c'estd un lieu de vie un autre
appartement et là on est à la à la
cisure entre le moment où on a un jardin
complètement fermé et on va avoir un
jardin complètement lié au château
avec Louis X et Anne de Bretagne le
jardin s'étend sur tout le pourtour du
château à Blois le jardin et le château
sont conçus comme un tout comme un
ensemble architectural à part entière et
c'est la première
fois donc il va créer des grandes
terrasses et ça c'est aussi
caractéristique du jardin la Renaissance
on va pas hésiter à faire des travaux
c'est un c'est une œuvre d'architecture
un jardin à la raissance donc il va
créer des grand jardin on raconte même
qu'il a aplani les collines de Blois
pour faire ses jardins à Blois
l'horticulteur patcelo d' Mercogliano
venu d'Italie pour servir le roi va
donner libre cours à toute sa
créativité le but de pachelo
d'amercoliano à travers ses jeux de
terrasse ça va être de créer des
tableaux paysagés on va vraiment
favoriser l'esthétisme du jardin on va
vraiment
enrichir par des jeux de couleurs des
jeux d'odeur qui vont permettre au
promeneurs de participer un peu à ce jeu
de la nature de vivre un peu le
jardin en
1515 Louis X
[Musique]
meurt François 1er lui succède sur le
trône de
France le nouveau roi est séduit par
cette propriété aux dimensions
gigantesque
[Musique]
après les guerres d'Italie et sa
victoire de Marignan il offre au valde
Loire avec la nouvelle aelle qu'il fait
bâtir sa fascination pour l'art
[Musique]
italien
les choses ont changé l'architecture
n'est plus une architecture de brique on
adopte maintenant une belle pierre de
taille blanche et de ce point de vue là
et bien le château construit par
François 1ier est un château plus
luxueux
12 et lumineuse la pierre blanche de
tufo utilisée pour la première fois pour
une maison royale va devenir l'identité
culturelle même du Val de
Loire François prier fait bâtir l'aile
des Loges une galerie rythmée par des
logia directement inspiré de
l'architecture italienne qui est
particulièrement spectaculaire à la nuit
tombée cette aile dite d'éloge est un
bouleversement dans l'histoire de
l'architecture française car jusqu'à
préssent l'on avait adopté sur des
châteaux au silhouettes encore
médiévales un décor venu d'Italie àèle
des Loges construite par François 1er on
adopte une structure qui elle vient
directement de
l'Italie
l'art italien entre à Blois par la
grande porte avec l'ile François 1er
dont l'élément central est un véritable
chef-dœuvre
[Musique]
d'architecture l'escalier à vis de forme
octogonale que l'écrivain Balzac disait
fouillé comme un ivoir de Chine est
couvert de fines sculptures d'ornements
italiens et d'emblèmes royaux stle fleu
propre au château de la
[Musique]
Loire je pense que François prier a une
idée essentielle pour la monarchie
française et l'état de toute façon la
notion de spectacle c'est la première
fois à Blois que le pouvoir se met en
scène prend un aspect théâtral avec le
fameux
[Musique]
escalier
les balcons qui se trouvent de chaque
côté du fameux escalier de Blois ne sont
pas là par hasard ils permettent aux
courtisans de voir circuler le souverain
qui aime bien
[Musique]
apparaître avec le nouveau roi la mode
italienne triomphe dans la décoration et
Blois est une immense fête
la cour fait assaut de luxe et de
plaisir le château brille dans un
tourbillon de réception plus
spectaculaire les unes que les
autres la présentation au 16e siècle des
plats est extraordinaire on présente des
hérons reconstitués des choses comme ça
ça fait la table est un vrai
spectacle mais ce qui fait la fierté de
François 1 ce sont les jardins dont il
fait lescrains de fête désormais
légendaire
le jardin devient un moyen de développer
l'art de vivre l'art de recevoir la cour
au château de la divertir de la
présenter finalement de la mettre en
valeur par une sorte de spectacle de
cours
[Musique]
permanent il est tellement fier que lors
du séjour du prince de mantou un prince
italien il lui fait faire l'entière
visite du château cette visite est
restée célèbre grâce à la lettre du
secrétaire du prince qui raconte qu'elle
s'est achevée dans les combles par un
épisode qui à l'époque a fait
jazer donc on se trouve dans les combles
aujourd'hui du château de lois
c'est-à-dire le 3ème niveau au-dessus
des appartements officiels du roi et de
la reine alors ces pièces étaient
dévolues à des logements les logements
des demoiselles qu'on cite dans la
lettre de Stasio Gadio au duc de tout
ces pièces aujourd'hui ont perdu leur
fonction d'origine on s'en sert comme
réserve mais c'est là qu'on pouvait
loger ces demoiselles une vingtaine on
pense du temps de Claude de France de
jeunes femmes de la suite de la reine et
il commence à lui faire faire le tour du
propriétaire je vais vous emmener vers
le dortoir enfin les chambres il dit
exactement les chambres des
demoiselle mais le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que Françis n'entend pas y
faire une simple visite de
courtoisie on peut supposer
effectivement c'était pour avoir des
relation d galante avec les les dames et
Stasio Gadio donc le jeune homme qui
raconte le secrétaire dit bah on est
resté à l'extérieur et puis il dit pas
ce qui se passe exactement après on les
a retrouvé ensuite dans l'antichambre
alors ensuite il y a eu beaucoup de on a
beaucoup glosé qu'est-ce qui s'était
passé il a pas osé raconter alors on
sait pas s'il a pas osé raconter mais en
tout cas il a quand même été
effectivement surpris
par l'attitude du roi qu' on va se
passer un bon moment on va voir les
nooiselles on voit pour les Italiens ça
les a quand même
[Musique]
surpris François 1er a laissé un autre
trésor à Blois qui sera quelques années
plus tard le cabinet de la reine
Catherine de
mdicis cette merveille de la Renaissance
recèle de nombreux mystères c'est le
studio
low
nous trouvons dans le studiolo qui est
le terme italien qui désigne en fait un
bureau alors il a comme intérêt surtout
d'être l'une des rares pièces de ce type
conservé aujourd'hui en
Europe on va trouver h placards
dissimulé le système d'ouverture se
trouve dans la
plainte
ces placards dissimulés dans les
boiseries sont à l'origine de la légende
dit des poisons qui entoure Catherine
deid6 Catherine de6 était une femme
étrangère une femme de grand pouvoir
donc il était aisé et facile de lui
attribuer ce genre de
pratique
ces magnifiques décors nous rappellent
que le château royal de Blois fut la
demeure de se rois et 10 reenes de
France il est aussi un condensé des
différents styles d'architecture que
l'on peut trouver dans le Val de Loire
c'est le frère de Louis XI Gaston
d'Orléan qui fit bâtir au 17e siècle
dans un style classique l'aile qui
achèvera la construction du
château
[Musique]
mais revenons à la
Renaissance François 1ier qui a fait de
son pouvoir un véritable spectacle dans
le château de Blois va franchir un pas
de plus dans la représentation de son
autorité il va faire construire le
château le plus mystérieux de
l'architecture française le château de
[Musique]
chambor
le château de chambor c'est un château
idéal c'est un comment dire un bâtiment
un petit peu utopique de ce point de vue
là c'est un château de rêve et et tout
est
[Musique]
possible et la première utopie de
François 1er c'est de choisir pour
édifier son château où il viendra pour
chasser une région de for gibboyeuse et
de
marécage c'est un défi extraordinaire
chambor il est unique par sa conception
il est édifié sur un terrain mouvant il
faudra des milliers des milliers de
pilotis l'eau sera une menace
permanente jusqu'à 1800 ouvriers vont
venir édifier cette surprenante création
architecturale qui défie les éléments
mais au-delà de l'immense presse
technique de ce chantier l'objectif du
souverain avec ce château est d'inscrire
dans la pierre la dimension sacrée de la
royauté tout à Chambord exprime l'idée
que dans le royaume tout tempend vers le
roi et que dans le royaume tout émane du
roi et idée il l'exprime à travers sa
structure qui est une structure en croix
les quatre galeries en croix qui verge
vers le centre au centre où se trouve le
double escalier ce double escalier qui
exprime une ascendance vers le lanternon
central lui-même coiffé de la couronne
et de la fleur de
lis et c'est la première fois que le
pouvoir monarchique ose
s'interposer entre la Terre et Dieu il
est plus haut que les
clochers le plan centré du château
repose sur un corps central parfaitement
carré en croix grecque comme celui de
plusieurs églises italienne de
l'époque un château à la dimension
féérique un château majestueux dont
l'escalier est un véritable
[Musique]
chefdœuvre
cet escalier est composé de deux hélices
entrreelacé quand on emprunte finalement
l'un des escaliers et bien on ne croise
pas les gens qui empruntent eux
l'autre c'est un escalier à double
révolution voilà comment on
l'appelle cet escalier à double
révolution s'inscrit dans le décor sous
des voûtes à caisson orné de l'emblème
Royal la salamandre on peut y voir
encore aujourd'hui le logi Royal
constitué d'un remarquable
oratoire tout ici est fait pour
surprendre tout est absolument
[Musique]
nouveau un château qui tellement
original que toute l'urope en
[Musique]
parle
le premier visiteur etblou et charlequin
qui va dire dans une phrase célèbre
c'est laabégée de ce que peut faire le
génie
humain François 1ier devient un roi
bâtisseur
[Musique]
exceptionnel Charles quin l'empereur du
Saint-Empire romain germanique est
l'ennemi légendaire de François Ier lors
d'un voyage dans les Flandres il est
contraint de traverser le royaume de
France François 1ier l'invite à chambor
avec le dessin de
l'impressionné à chambor une tablette
tactile restitue en trois dimensions les
décors du château tels qu'ils étaient au
16e siècle ainsi une chambre est
entièrement habillée pour sa venue de
tentures noires et or la chambre qui a a
reçu charlequin recouvre sous nos yeux
son décor du 18 décembre
1539 nous avions à cette époque des
nattes de Jaun pour pouvoir isoler du
froid c'est important dans ces logies de
faire des aménagements he pour les
rendre agréables et faciles à chauffer
donc des teintures sur les murs et des
nattes au
sol élément très intéressant aussi nous
avions la description dans les documents
du garde-meubles des teintures du lit de
charlequin nous avons recréé le lit pour
comprendre comment est constituer un lit
à la
Renaissance la description précise
retrouvée dans les archives du lit dans
lequel l'empereur charlequin a dormi
témoigne de l'art de vivre à la
Renaissance couverture en tafteta
oreillers et traversins matelas de plume
sous matatelas en matière végétale
tressée le confort et l'esthétisme rien
n'est laissé au hasard pour
impressionner l'empereur même pour une
seule
nuit nous avons placé aussi un élément
un peu symbolique c'est une arquebuse
qui rappelle que François 1 et
charlequin ont chassé ensemble le 18
décembre 1539 juste avant de venir à
chambor
dormir François 1er à conier Charles qu
a partagé avec lui une grande battue
dans l'immense parc de chambor
le grand projet du roi enfire un
véritable temple de la
chasse et à chambor la vraie nouveauté
c'est que le roi crée une vraie réserve
de chasse une notion qui est assez
moderne avec tout un personnel qui
représente le roi
ici ce qui rend ce domaine exceptionnel
c'est qu'il est encore aujourd'hui le
plus grand parc clos
d'Europe le roi chasse avec des
centaines de personnes que ce soit des
Vallé de limers qui s'occupent des
chiens que ce soit les rabatteurs les
canardiers si on chasse au canard les
renardiers si on chasse des animaux
nuisibles il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
personnels qui suit le roi dans ses
chasses c'est un art c'est l'art de
chasser et François 1er est le premier
veneur à défendre cet art de
chasser
mais la chasse royale par excellence est
celle du SER un moyen pour François
prier d'impressionner son visiteur en le
conviant à partager avec lui cette
activité c'est une activité qui montre
l'autorité d'un personnage qui montre sa
puissance et seul le Roi peut déléguer
ce pouvoir à des nobles donc c'est déjà
montré sa place dans la société que de
chasser comme d'un outil diplomatique un
outil que l'on utilisera jusque sous la
5e République Val cardestin inv vite par
exemple ici Juan Carlos peut après sa
monter sur le trône d'Espagne alors on
imagine que c'est un moment privilégié
passer ensemble à pratiquer une activité
de loisirs une activité aussi qui montre
les valeurs de la France on est dans une
tradition ici qui montre vraiment l'art
de vivre à la française Val
t deux souriants et très détendus
quelques minutes de pause pour les
journalistes et le chef de l'État et son
hôte se dirigeent vers les Land Rover
qui devaient les conduire sur les lieux
de la batue au
sanglier cette tradition véritable
survivance monarchique va perdurer
jusqu'en
2010 l'une des plus incroyables
constructions que le siècle de la
nous est laissée sera totalement achevé
au 17e
[Musique]
siècle nous sommes de retour à Blois
dans la salle du roi la salle du roi est
la pièce publique des appartements ro à
la Renaissance c'est là que François
1ier prend ses repas et donne audience
sous ce DA c'est un lieu d'ostentation
du pouvoir tout manifeste la puissance
du souverain et la richesse du royaume
la salle conserve d'ailleurs une
cheminée qui est peinte et dorée sur
laquelle se trouve l'emblème et
l'effigie de François 1er la salamandre
et les fleurs de Liss ainsi que celle de
la Reine Claude de France
l'hermine dans les années 1520 une femme
brille à la cour de François 1ier c'est
Diane de Poitier elle est dame d'honneur
de la reine claude
elles se sont certainement promené ici
dans cette galerie somptueuse qui était
un lieu de promenade intérieure d'où
l'on pouvait admirer les jardins la
galerie de la reine c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appelle était aussi destinée au
divertissement et aux réceptions c'est
la raison pour laquelle on retrouve un
petit trésor du 16e siècle ce clavsin
italien de 15
172 Diane de Poitier vit donc dans
l'entourage des enfants de France petit
à petit elle va devenir pour eux comme
une seconde maman et plus précisément
pour le petit Henry le futur Henri I
avec qui elle va nouer une relation très
étroite c'est lui d'ailleurs qui lui
offrira l'un des plus beaux trésors du
Val de Loire le Château de
[Musique]
chenonau
en
1547 le fils de François 1er Henri II
monte sur le trône il a épousé 15 ans
plus tôt Catherine de Médicis mais n'a
Dieu que pour sa favorite la belle Diane
de Poitier
elle est la femme la plus influente du
royaume et veut un château dans le
prestigieux valde
Loire
[Musique]
le château de Chenonceau est sans doute
le plus original de tous les châteaux de
la Loire parce qu'il a été conçu comme
un palais vénitien par rapport à
l'eau il n'est pas au bord du chair il
enjambe le
chair Chenon vient d'être construit par
l'intendant général des Finances du roi
un certain Thomas boet à la différ des
autres châteaux de la Loire bâtis sur
des forteresses médiévales c'est
l'environnement qui a été prédominant
pour le choix de son
emplacement il va faire construire son
château sur les piles d'un ancien moulin
dans le cours du
Cher donc chenono est exceptionnel dans
le sens où son architecture s'inscrit à
merveille dans le paysage qui l'entoure
et notamment dans le lit de la rivière
le château bâti par Boyet est tout à
fait dans le goût de la
renaissance de larges fenêtres à menau
des lucarnes en pierre blanche de
tufo Diane va ajouter un pont à arcade
jusqu'à l'autre rive du Cher elle fera
de chenonau un chef-dœuvre on est dans
un geste architectural tel que l'on se
soucie de la beauté des façades qu'il
compose avec leur symétrie leur
régularité et par conséquent leur
harmonie Diane a une vision pour
chenonau
entourer le château de jardins qui vont
magnifier la
demeure un jardin va sortir de terre qui
sera l'un des plus innovants de ce temps
on imagine qu'à l'époque où Dian de
Poitier Acquier chenonau elle elle fait
construire ce jardin sur un champ ancien
champ d'orge qu'on aménage de manière à
isoler une partie de la berge pour en
faire une sorte
d'île au total il faudra des centaines
d'ouvriers des milliers de tombau de
pierre et de terre à gazon pour réaliser
ce qui s'appelle toujours aujourd'hui le
jardin de
Dian
[Musique]
l'intention de Dian de Poitier quand
elle construit ce jardin c'est de créer
une impression de surprise mais aussi
d'opulence on a des dessins très très
riches de par terre on essaie vraiment
de donner quelque chose de très
artistique Diane veut faire de sa
nouvelle résidence le cadre idéal pour
recevoir la cour et le roi
mais le 30 juin
1559 Henry I est mortellement blessé à
Paris lors d'un
tournoi pour Diane tout va changer elle
va devoir quitter
chenonau Catherine de micis qui détient
les clés du pouvoir va vouloir le
récupérer pour en faire un outil
politique dans un royaume soumis aux
guerr de religion
Chenonceau va devenir un instrument de
son pouvoir
elle n'efface pas la trace de Dian à
chenonau elle l'utilise en faisant
édifier deux galeries superposées sur le
pont construit par la
favorite il au niveau paysager quelque
chose d'extraordinaire cette galerie sur
le Cher c'est quand même sans équivalent
ailleurs c'est quelque chose d'un petit
peu magique l'image de Chenon est
[Musique]
magique ces galeries forment un espace
de réception unique au monde et donnent
au château son aspect
actuel un château a une fonction
d'apparat d'ostentation d'exhibition et
c'est notamment le sens qu'à la galerie
mais en même temps le châelin a besoin
d'un lieu où se replier ù se mettre à
l'abri du monde et ça c'est la fonction
du cabinet ou dans ce qu'on appelle le
studiolo à Chenonceau pour Catherine de
mdicis c'est le cabinet vert qui a cette
fonction son plafond à caisson en bois
de chaîne est
remarquable un des premiers plafons
italiens en
France mais Catherine ne se contente pas
de ses modifications décoratives
elle agrandit le jardin et conçoit un
jardin sensoriel aux odeurs nouvelles et
raffinées
elle en fait des lieux de fête et de
réception on y danse on va écouter de la
musique on va aussi profiter bien
évidemment des feux d'artifice au-dessus
du
[Musique]
Cher les fêtes dans les jardins de
chenono vont servir à une stratégie pour
pacifier le royaume elles vont réunir
les différentes forces politiques afin
de les faire coexister autour de la
personne du
roi au-delà de l'esthétique tous ces
changement servent la politique de la
reine depuis son château de Chenonceau
Catherine dedicis dirige un royaume mis
à feu et à sang par les guardes de
religion
elle sait que pour maintenir la paix
dans son royaume entre catholiques et
protestants elle devra user de ruse
Chenon est le cadre idéal de sa
stratégie il y a l'idée de rassembler
catholique et protestant au moins
pendant l'espace d'un divertissement
elle aime à faire c'est elle-même qui
l'écrit elle aime à faire baler ensemble
c'est dire danser ensemble papiste et
HUG
la menace d'une guerre civile entre
catholiques et protestants est nourrie
par la rivalité entre deux grands
seigneurs le duc de Guise côté
catholique et côté protestant le prince
de Condé entre les deux Catherine sait
qu'elle devra s'armé de ruse et
mobiliser les femmes il faut bien
comprendre que les gentilshommes sont
des soldats la présence des femmes les
oblige à une maîtrise de
soi
lors de la soirée du 13 avril
1563 dans les cuisines de chenonau on
s'affire Catherine de micis donne une
réception et joue son
atoucharme le fameux escadron volant un
groupe de jeunes femmes bien nées dévoué
à la reine et qui intrigue autour des
deux grands princes pour mieux connaître
leurs
intentions c'est un véritable réseau
d'espionnage qui est mise en place dans
la nouvelle
galerie mais le destin donnera d'autres
rôles à cette pièce
[Musique]
historique c'est au 20e siècle qu'elle
deviendra hôpital militaire durant la
Première Guerre mondiale et aura pendant
la seconde une fonction héroïque
aussi incongru que cela puisse paraître
la ligne de démarcation longeant le cour
du Cher passait juste au milieu du
château l'entrée principale était en
zone occupée tandis que le pont Levie
donnait sur la France
libre il est arrivé qu'à la nuit tombée
la galerie de Catherine dans le silence
de ces murs
séculaires permett à ceux qui fuyaient
la barbarie de passer en zone
libre
[Musique]
il reste assez peu de chef-dœuvre de la
Renaissance Chen en est un mais il en
existe un autre à quelques kilomètres
c'est as le rideau qui parce qu'il était
en péril fait actuellement l'objet d'une
restauration les reflets donnent
l'impression que le château est un
vaisseau qui
avance
Azel rideau est un bijou c'est le
diamant de l'Indre on peut dire que
c'est un concentré du style des châteaux
de la Loire la Renaissance c'est presque
une miniature en quelque sorte
absolument
ravissante c'est Gill Bertelot le
conseiller du roi Louis XI et trésorier
de France qui fait bâtir le château
d'azel rideau en
une grande campagne de restauration est
à l'œuvre pour lui rendre sa splendeur
elle va durer 3
ans vous voyez ici que la façade ouest
est vraiment couverte recouverte de
liquen et de mousse donc il va falloir
nettoyer au micrablage au microlaser et
au scalpel et à la vapeur c'est un
travail chirurgical l'ennemi des
châteaux des châteaux de la Loire
l'ennemi du tufo c'est la pollution bien
sûr elle est présente et puis
l'humidité un travail chirurgical et de
longue haleine qui va permettre au
restaurateur de retrouver l'aspect
lumineux de la pierre de tufo sur les
5425 m C de façade du
château chaque pierre de la façade est
numérotée et
ensuite on va avec les restaurateurs les
tailleurs de Pierr l'architecte en chef
des monuments historiques sur les échaf
age pour identifier quelles pierres
doivent être
changé les tailleurs de pierre
remplacent les blocs de tufo
détériorés ces artisans d'art
travaillent avec les mêmes outils et les
mêmes techniques que les tailleurs du
16e
siècle alors le chapitau qui existait
auparavant était très abîmé la lecture
était presque impossible donc le
sculpteur supierre a a fait un relevé de
cette sculpture d'origine il a fait
valider par l'architecte en chef des
monuments historiques et maintenant il
resculpte le
chapitau la qualité des sculptures du
château d'Azé témoigne des talents alors
réunis dans la région au 16e siècle par
les command royales et
aristocratiques ici la pierre ne va pas
être remplacée on va laisser en l'état
c'estàd que même si y a nos yeux elle
semble altéré elle est suffisamment
lisible pour que on la laisse en place
et qu'on ne la resculpte pas parce que
c'est du patrimoine parce que ça vient
de nos ancêtres les compagnons du 16e
siècle qui ont fait le même travail et
qu'il faut laisser cette trace au
maximum les sculptures ont également
beaucoup souffert des restaurations
précédentes
utilisant des mortiers trop durs qui
empêch le travail naturel de la pierre
au fil du
temps c'est pourquoi le strict respect
de la matière d'origine est la clé de
voûte du chantier de restauration mené
aujourd'hui alors à chaque fois c'est
vraiment une quête de cette authenticité
un respect véritablement du caractère du
monument qui est déterminé par des
matériaux locaux par exemple pour le
mortier on fait attention à utiliser
une ch accompagné et mélangé avec un
sable du Val de Loire tout simplement
pour respecter l'implantation du château
il faut pas oublier que le château
d'azel rideau a été construit au 16e
siècle et qu'on utilisait des matériaux
de
proximité la charpente du château d'azel
rideau véritable vaisseau de chîne est
un témoignage exceptionnel des
charpentes du 16e siècle mais quelques
pièces de bois sont très endommagées par
des infiltrations
d'eau le chîn qui a servi à faire cette
charpente provient de la forêt de Chinon
juste à côté hein François prier en 1517
signe une lettre qui autorise gilbertelo
à couper tout le bois dont il a besoin
pour faire son château on étudie la les
cernes de l'âge du bois qui nous permet
de dire que le bois a été coupé entre
novembre et mars de l'hiver 1518 1519
donc c'est bien bien la charpente
d'origine et donc cette charpente est
quasiment intacte depuis le 16e siècle
donc la restauration concerne
principalement quelques morceaux de
charpente mais surtout la
toiture l'équipe de charpentier uvrera
pendant plus de 12
mois sur les 1838 m Carr de charpente 35
seulement devrai être remplacé
[Musique]
l'art du tracé de charpente est inscrit
par l'UNESCO comme savoir-faire
traditionnel sur la liste du patrimoine
immatériel de
l'humanité quand on dit qu'on restaure
cette charpente là et on se dit qu'elle
peut refaire 400 500 ans c'est c'est
vrai que c'est c'est
incroyable
toute restauration réserve ses surprises
sous la couverture d'ardoise des combles
du château les charpentiers ont fait une
découverte qui nous transporte au 19e
siècle un casque et un soldat prussien
gravé sur un
enduit en 1870 l'état-major prussien
s'est installé au château d'azelridau et
donc a occupé les e pendant un certain
temps à leur
départ la d'ailleurs la la
mère du marquis de
biancour les a regardé partir et a dit
messieurs je ne vous salue point nous
avions eu les GO les visigos les
ostrogos il nous manquait plus que les
[Musique]
Saligos si la Renaissance que l'on tente
de préserver à AZF et la réputation du
Val de Loire c'est grâce à la présence
des souverains français l'un des
derniers grands rois avoir marqué le Val
de Loire et probablement Henri II nous
nous trouvons ici dans ces appartements
où s'est commis un assassina en effet le
23 décembre
1588 nous sommes en pleine guerre de
religion Henri II fait assassiner celui
qui voulait le destituer le duc de Guise
et c'est dans cette chambre au pied de
ce lit que le duc de Guise s'est écroulé
avant de mourir si Henri I a marqué le
Val de Loire les souverains français à
partir de François 1er vont lentement le
délaisser et se tourner vers une autre
région Paris tout d'abord puis
Versailles au 17e siècle de résidence
principales les châteaux du Val-de Loire
vont devenir des résidences de passage
ils ne sont plus au cœur de la vie
politique les abords du fleuve vont
devenir le cadre des plus beaux jardins
que l'on puisse imaginer grâce à la des
sol et du climat les châteaux se
transformaient en écrin d'une vie
brillante et
raffinée à l'Est d'AZ le rideau un
château se distingue des autre par son
style unique en son genre c'est le
château de Cheverny qui marque un
tournant dans l'histoire du Val de
Loire le chteau ch vernis construit de
1604 à 1634 n'est pas du tout un château
de la Renaissance c'est un château de
style classique et avec lui on peut dire
qu' est inventé en valde Loire le style
Louis
[Musique]
XI lorsque Paris redevient
officiellement la capitale du royaume
les châteaux deviennent les demeures de
plaisance des grands
seigneurs celui de Philippe hurau de
cheverni garde des sauts d'Henri
appartient toujours à la même famille
depuis plus de 10 siècles le marquis
charles-anttoine de vibret en est le
descendant alors là on est dans le grand
salon du Château et c'est véritablement
un lieu d'échange un lieu de réception
c'est un salon d'ailleurs une pièce qui
qui fait son apparition qui n'existait
pas avant dans les châteaux
raissances dans ces châteaux qui sont en
fait des lieux de vie on se cultive on
apprend on parle on discute on échange
on peut jouer de la musique cet art de
recevoir va symboliser cheverni et avec
le 17e siècle le Val de Loire devient la
région de prédilection des amateurs de
demeure de
plaisance ainsi l'un des hommes les plus
importants de la cour de Louis XIV le
marquis de valentinet acquire un château
près de la ville de tour le château
du
[Musique]
il est aujourd'hui une propriété privée
le duc de blackas et sa famille y réside
depuis de
siècles et ce qui marque à c'est que le
jardin n'a pas changé depuis le 17e
siècle
les remarcables jardins à la française
ont été faits par Le Nôtre
lui-même au 17e siècle apparaît le
jardin la française qui abandonne les
pratiques du jardin Renaissance qui
était un jardin d' compartimenté avec
des parterres borduré de végétaux au
profit d'une autre logique qui est celle
de grande perspective destiné à
permettre au maître du jardin d'avoir
sous les yeux l'ensemble de son jardin
et même éventuellement le paysage qui
s'étend
au-delà le Petitfils du marquis Louis
hérite du château en
1700 avec lui et devient un lieu mondain
où les lettrés parisiens aiment profiter
d'une vie
[Musique]
champêtre le marquis de valentinet a
reçu Voltaire il a dû recevoir fon
peut-être madame de sévignier il a reçu
tout ce que le le royaume pouvait
compter comme beaux
esprits ce que l'on appelle un salon
littéraire
aujourd'hui Charles perraot qui a une
maison dans les environs est un ami du
marquis du C il est un habitué de ses
conversations et trouve au château une
grande source
[Musique]
d'inspiration c'est là que l'homme de
lettre fait naître Aurore la Belle au
bois dormant le premier de ces te publié
dans le Mercure galant de
1696 le château du C le type même du
château de de conte de fée du château de
rêve toutes ces tours un peu mystérieux
ces toit
pointu cette pierre très blanche il y
avait des loups sans doute en forê
Chinon à l'époque tous les ingrédients
sont là pour imaginer un conte
merveilleux au sens noble du terme
depuis le compteur légendaire les fé les
reines et autres princes charmants du
château du C font rêver les petites
[Musique]
filles si le siècle de Louis XIV a
révélé la vie de château dans le Val de
Loire le 18e siècle va consacrer l'art
de la conversation qui exige d'avoir de
l'esprit et du goût une femme possède
toutes ses qualités et incarne cet art
de vivre c'est la marquise de
Pompadour la grande et puissante
favorite de Louis XV va marquer le Val
de Loire avec son château de
[Musique]
Ménard fermé au public nous avons eu le
rare privilège de pouvoir accéder à ce
domaine c'est un château qui est
apaisant certainement pour les nerfs de
Madame de Pompadour qui sont des nerfs
qui sont soumis à dur épreuve pendant
qu'elle vit à Versailles et là c'est
disons la Touren c'est un lieu de
retraite au bon sens du terme et de
repos
Madame de Pompadour a la folie des
châteaux elle a des châteaux partout où
elle refait un décor
intérieur alors ici c'est un
amameublement pour autant qu'on sache
extrêmement plus que raffiné luxueux qui
provient des meilleur éénistes
parisiens les peintes sont ses amis
madameadour c'est une femme des lumières
donc tout ce qui compte dans le monde
littéraire intellectuel et artistique
est en accord avec elle elletient ce
qu'elle
veut c'est à jacquange Gabriel le
premier architecte du roi qu'elle
demande de dessiner les
décors château de mard ve ce qui est
rare tous les décors de ce que l'on
appellera le style
Pompadour des boiseries aux lignes plus
droite et l'apparition de guirlande de
fleurs Madame de Pompadour fait de
Ménard une résidence moderne à son goût
elle restructure complètement
l'intérieur elle organise pour elle un
appartement qui comprend une chambre un
boudoir une salle de bain dans la
laquelle elle fait accrocher un certain
nombre de miroirs pivotant de façon que
depuis sa baignoire elle puisse voir la
Loire au rez-de-chaussée il y a toute
une enfilade de
salon et la grande nouveauté du 18e
siècle c'est la salle à manger où la
marquise donne de grands
banquets la cuisine n'est pas au
sous-sol immédiatement elle a fait
aménager les cuisines dans les
communs avec un corridor souterrain qui
conduisait directement à la salle à
manger sans doute pour ne pas être
incommodé par les odeurs de cuisine et
puis aussi par la
domesticité du durant 4 années Madame de
Pompadour va recevoir à Ménard tout ce
que le siècle compte d'intellectuels et
d'artistes le temps semble suspendu dans
ce château loin de l'agitation de la
cour et de la
capitale on n'a jamais porté l'art de la
conversation aussi haut qu'au 18e siècle
cet air de la conversation c'est un art
qui est typiquement français où l'on
parle de tout à condition de ne pas être
ennuyeux et cette conversation permet
des gratigner mais des gratiger en
douceur ceux qui ne sont pas là bien
[Musique]
évidemment à la mort de Madame de
Pompadour en
1764 son frère le marquis de marignnie
éérite du
château il va faire à Ménard un joyau de
verdure des parteres de gazons orné de
statues Madame de Pompadour en a une à
son
effigie il crée ce que l'on va appeler
un jardin à
l'anglaise
c'est le jardin où la nature semble
dominer par rapport aux artifices qui
ont cour dans les jardins la française
et tout cela à l'époque de Rousseau
c'est des choses qui séduisent les
spectateurs qui croient trouver
davantage d'authenticité et surtout qui
trouve quelque chose qui parle à la
sensibilité et non plus à la seule
raison al le 18e siècle est de plus en
plus un siècle
sensible
les jardins de rocklin sont sans doute
le plus bel exemple de jardins à
l'anglaise qui existent aujourd'hui dans
le Val de
Loire les petits sentiers tortueux
remplacent les aller
rctilines les formes irrégulières
succèdent aux parteres de
fleurs la nature retrouve en apparence
sa
spontanéité pourtant si on l'examine
d'un peu plus près on découvre une
nature agancée avec esprit et avec un
idéal qui annonce le
[Musique]
romantisme cette douceur de vivre va se
trouver brusquement interrompu à la
Révolution française qui va faire des
châteaux des symboles de l'Ancien Régime
je me trouve ici dans la salle dite de
la salamandre au château de Blois c'est
dans cette salle que l'on peut voir les
traces laissées par les
révolutionnaire en effet le château de
Blois est transformé en caserne en 1788
8 ce qui le sauve mais il aura à subir
la destruction des emblèmes royaux au
19e siècle avant de procéder à la
restauration du château on a fait mouler
les restes des décors disparus pour en
garder témoignage on voit d'ailleurs ici
les traces des outils destructeurs sur
ces moulages des décors du grand
escalier les salamandres ont disparu
mais la révolution n'a pas eu raison des
trésors du valde Loire elle va laisser
la place au Premier Empire qui n'aura de
cesse de vouloir retrouver l' faste et
la façon de vivre de l'Ancien Régime
Napoléon estime qu'il faut de grandes
maisons pour les gens qui occupent de
grands emploi il va même pour beaucoup
de ses haut dignitaires pousser et aider
financièrement ce fut le cas pour son
ministre des Relations Extérieures le
grand Charles Maurice de taléran à qui
il fait acquérir le château de
[Musique]
valenay
en arrivant au domaine de Valenca en
1803 taléran commence par embellir le
château il en fait une synthèse des
styles du valde Loire le style
Renaissance et le style
classique le château est destiné à
refléter la touteepuissance du ministre
et devenir un lieu de rendez-vous
diplomatique et chez le prince de
taléron cela se passe à table
taland disait qu'il n'y a pas de bonne
diplomatie sans bonne
cuisine c'était là où les grandes
discussions se faisaient et c'était là
où les choses pouvaient être finalement
peut-être après signé ou pas en fonction
des discussions c'est tout l'art de la
gastronomie
diplomatique Talan avait à son service
celui qui révolutionner la cuisine et la
pâtisserie en utilisant uniquement des
produits frais le chef Antonin
carem sur la table sont disposés tous
les plats du repas entrée plat de
résistance et dessert c'est ce que l'on
a appelé le service à la
française donc c'était un grand
spectacle de
réjouissance et vous aviez la spécialité
d'Antonin carê les croqus en bouche les
pièces MONT les pièces montées qui
étaient des vrais
spectacles vous aviez des cascades
modernes des temples chinois tout ça mis
autour comme ça comme un tableau un
tableau de
sucre Antonin carem restera 12 ans au
service du prince dont la table va
devenir une des plus grandes table de
l'Empire les cuisines de Valena sont
extraordinaire magnifique et
considérable et certainement talrand
descendait à valencer au cuisin et
surveillait la composition des
menus il y a quelques 15 à 20 personnes
au moins dans les cuisines de Valenca
c'est
considérable même en dehors de Paris
taléran se donne tout entier à la
politique c'est la politique qui va
modifier le destin de
valenin cet endroit qui était destiné à
montrer le prestige de la République
puis de de l'Empire va finir par devenir
une prison une prison oui mais une
prison
[Applaudissements]
royale sur les conseils de taléran en
1808 Napoléon envahit l'Espagne et
d'éloge du trône la famille
royale mais en de cette même année
l'insurrection gagne la
péninsule furieux de se retrouver
empêtré dans ce bourbier espagnol
Napoléon décide de faire payer à taléran
ses mauvais conseils et ordonne que
Valencin abrite l'exil des princes de la
famille royale Ferdinand roi d'Espagne
et son frère
Carlos la cour d'Espagne arrive avec des
centaines de personnes on essaie
d'aménager t extrêmement respectueux
vis-à-vis des Princes il reproduit à
l'échelle de Valenca une cour
espagnole le Prince va organiser pour
elle toutes sortes de
divertissements ce sont les dames qui
broderont l'ensemble de chaise de
salon à
l'extérieur promenades à cheval sont
deise mais aussi parties de chasse et
Séan d' crime le soir sont donné des
balles des concerts et talérant va même
ordonner la construction d'un petit
théâtre véritable bijou de
[Musique]
classicisme on fait venir une troupe de
théâtre et on joue évidemment des pièces
aussi peu Politi qui est aussi insipide
que
possible les princes espagnols
quitteront le château en 1813 après 6
années d'exil
doré taléran restera dans le Val de
Loire jusqu'à sa mort en
1838 au Premier Empire succède la
restauration puis la Monarchie de
Juillet le Second Empire et la 3e
république avec la belle époque le Val
de Loire va continuer de jouer son rôle
pour une nouvelle élite financiers et
industriels vont s'appropri la vie de
[Musique]
château le lieu le plus emblématique de
cette tendance est sans doute le château
de
[Musique]
Candé ce petit château du 16e siècle est
acquis en 1927 par un couple
d'industriels franco-américains Charles
et ferern
budau milliardaires ils font de Candé un
château sans équivalent dans la région
une demeure d'un incroyable
confort grâce à sa fortune très
importante il va pouvoir développer des
installations assez extraordinaires et
vraiment à la la pointe de la
technologie pour cette époque donc ça va
être l'installation par exemple pour le
château d'un chauffage
centralisé faire une installation d'eau
courante systématique jusque sous les
toits de cette demeure l'électricité
dans toutes les salles qui étaient
produites directement dans le parc voilà
un petit peu des exemples d'installation
remarquables qu'il met au point en
27 ainsi chacune des h chambres est
pourvue d'une salle de bain alimentée en
courante et chaude à
volonté dans cette salle de bain donc on
trouve tous les éléments indispensable
tel que la baignoire par exemple un
détail très important c'est qu'il faut
savoir que tous les sanitaires ont été
orté directement des États-Unis puisque
les techniques de conception étaient
beaucoup plus
développées beaucoup de luxe dans le
décor de la mosaïque de pâte de verre
dans le style l'artco sur les murs du
bronze ou du cristal pour la
robinetterie près de 60 tonnes de tuyaux
sont cachés dans les murs dans les murs
Renaissance extrêmement épais finalement
dont on a une idée de l'épaisseur en
regardant la percée des
fenêtres à Candé le couple bedo mène une
vie à l'américaine dans une France qui
leur semble bien à la traain
Charles bedeau est un homme d'affaires
il a besoin d'être en contact permanent
avec les États-Unis or les moyens de
communication sont limités notamment
ceux du bureau des
postes il y a des contraintes à
respecter notamment les horaires
d'ouverture du du bureau c'est pas 7
jours sur 7 ni 24h sur 24 et petit à
petit en fouillant les archives donc on
s'aperçoit que Charles bedeau va
installer son propre centrale
téléphonique raccordé à celui de la
ville de tour
ça change tout puisqu'il y a une
opératrice qui travaille à demeure pour
que l'on puisse téléphoner directement
depuis le domaine à travers le monde
entier dans les années 30 donc c'est une
installation moderne extrêmement
remarquable à Candé la vie de château du
couple bed rime avec vie mondaine et
loisir tennis golf dans le parc mais
aussi salle de culture physique des
appareils innovants les mêmes que ceux
du Titanic sont installé dans le donjon
néogothique le sport entre dans les
mœurs la culture du corps devient très
importante on a le souci de pratiquer
des activités physiques et sportives
vraiment pour entretenir sa silhouette
avoir une silhouette fine et bien musclé
donc on est tout à fait dans dans cette
dimension
là
aux États-Unis Ferne bedo avait entamé
une carrière de
soprano pas question à Candé de renoncer
à son goût pour la musique le couple
fait appel à un grand facteur d'org
américain Ernest Martin skiner pour
installer un instrument au cœur de la
bibliothèque l'org de cand pr une place
dans le château puisqu'on le retrouve
sur trois niveaux différents
l'instrument a été totalement fait sur
mesure puisque tout est imbriqué entre
les les pans des murs donc ça a été un
travail de de
titan classé monument historique en
1993 cet org fait partie des trois
derniers modèles en état de
fonctionnement dans le
monde les bedau invité ponctuellement
des musiciens pour venir jouer ici et
nous savons que Marcel Dupré est venu
jouer ici plusieurs fois notamment le 3
juin 1937 à l'occasion du mariage du duc
de Winsor avec wall
Simpson américaine
roturière deux fois divorcée Wallis
Simpson vit le grand amour avec le
Prince Édouard duc de winzor et elle
fait scandale le couple bedau va lui
proposer son château caché au fond des
bois pour célébrer son mariage avec le
prince à l'abri des regards on voit la
signature dard au-dessus de WIS en
dessous et la date du mariage 3 6
37 la famille royale d'Angleterre
n'étant pas favorable à cette union le
plus compliqué fut de trouver un pasteur
anglican qui accepte de célébrer le
mariage religieux sans l'accord de sa
hiérarchie mais les bedau ont de
l'entregens et le mariage est célébré
juste avant l'été
alors nous arrivons au salon de musique
où s'est déroulé le mariage religieux on
voit en s'approchant de l'hôtel qui a
été mis là exprès pour la circonstance
la robe que portait WIS Simpson célèbre
évidemment par son bleu qu'on a surnommé
le bleu WIS puisque elle adorait cette
cette couleur qui semble-t-il allait
fort bien à ses
yeux seul 16 personnes assistent à ce
mariage du
siècle quelques années plus tard
soupçonné de collaboration car très
proche des nazis Charles bedo est arrêté
et incarcéré par les Américains en
1943 il se donne la mort un an plus
tard Charles bedau était quelqu'un de
très ambitieux et peut-être un petit peu
opportuniste dans le monde des affaires
ça lui a joué donc des tours sur sur la
fin de sa vie il n'a pas toujours traité
semble-t-il avec les bonnes
personnes comme Charles bedeau de
nombreux hommes fortunés font au début
du siècle l'acquisition de domaines dans
le Val de Loire pour assoir leur
position un médecin d'origine espagnole
le docteur joain Carvalo achète en 1906
un château au cœur d'un magnifique parc
à l'anglaise à 20 km à l'ouest de Candé
celui de
villandri avec lui ce sera un retour aux
sources il va faire revivre l'âge d'or
du Val de Loire la
Renaissance il est pas l'industriel
enrichi qui manifeste sa réussite en se
payant un château comme d'autres se paye
une danseuse lui le château il a une
fonction et le parc en particulier a une
fonction d'expression il est il est
quasiment un
créateur car join Carvallo a pour
Vilander un projet chercheurs il
découvre qu'au 16e siècle le château
disposait d'un grand jardin dont le
maître d'œuvre n'était autre que le
ministre des Finances de François 1 et
Carvallo arrive dans ce château et
décide de supprimer ce jardin à
langlaise donc panique à Vilander les
villageois comprennent pas il arrache
les glycines enfin bon c'est
extraordinaire et parce que il veut
retrouver l'esprit des anciens jardins à
la française et même Renaissance
Henri Carvallo est le petit-fils de
Joachin c'est lui qui dirige aujourd'hui
le château de villanderie avec la
rigueur qui fait les jardins
remarquables il a retrouvé le plan de
travail misise au point par son arrière-
grandr-père les jardins de vilanderie ne
sont pas une simple copie de
reproduction des traités d'architecture
ils sont une
réinvention
sur un hectare il va réaliser un jardin
à trois niveaux et ces trois terrasses
ont une dimension
symbolique mon arrière- grand-père jein
évoquait souvent l'idée qu'il avait que
il y a une équivalence entre ces trois
terrasses et l'être
humain et au niveau le plus bas se
trouve le jardin potager qui est le plus
emblématique comme étant la dimension
corporelle de l'être humain on y trouve
de de très nombreux légumes qui sont
faits pour qui sont
nourriciers on assemble dans ce potager
les légumes et les flores pour former
voyez un un un damier ou un échiquier
multicolore
[Musique]
décoratif au second niveau donc on on
trouvera les jardins d'ornement jardin
d'ornement où se trouve jardin d'amour
jardin de musique c'était en quelque
sorte le le mental ou
l'esprit
son troisème niveau qu'il trouvait le
plus spirituel en quelque sorte le
jardin d'eau c'était pour lui le niveau
correspondant à l'âme donc il y avait
dans cette composition de ces trois
terrasses une représentation un peu
symbolique de de l'être humain Carvalo
est quelqu'un qui a des des aspirations
intellectuelles philosophiques quasiment
religieuses même dans qui l'anime très
fortement et c'est dans cette optique
qu'il aborde vilanderie qu'il aborde
[Musique]
jardin pour le nouveau maître de
Vilander l'art dont font partie les
jardins doit conduire à une élévation de
[Musique]
l'âme et donc ce qu'il a voulu mettre en
œuvre à travers ses jardins c'est la
beauté et ce qu'elle apporte de
nécessaire à l'humain
avec
vilanderie ce sont les jardins
Renaissance qui ont repris vie il nous
rappelleent aujourd'hui ce que furent
l'écrain des châteaux de la Loire au 15e
et 16e
siècle les châteaux de la Loire nous
projettent dans une époque où l'appar et
le luxe sont érigés en modèle où la
beauté le plaisir et la fête ont un art
de
vivre avec les guerres et les ravages du
temps un grand nombre de ces
chef-dœuvres ont failli
disparaître grâce au CR d'alarme
d'écrivains et d'artistes bouleversés
par la vision des monuments en ruine la
valeur patrimoniale de cet héritage a
émergé dans les consciences et ce
désastre n'a pas eu lieu le Val de Loire
fut sauvé restauré valorisé et nous
invite aujourd'hui à partager son
univers son
atmosphère et sa
[Musique]
douceur vous aurez donc compris pourquoi
le Val de Loire est un haut lieu du
tourisme en France et pourquoi il est
classé patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
les châteaux ngériens sont parmi les
plus beaux trésors de France et c'est
dans le Val de ir que c'est écrit une
grande partie de notre culture commune
de notre identité de l'excellence à la
française j'espère que ce voyage à la
découverte de nos plus beaux
chef-dœuvres vous aura passionné quant à
moi je vous donne rendez-vous pour de
nouveaux trésors à
[Musique]
découvrir